[موسيقى]
على اثرها على وظائف المصرفي بشكل عام
وجهته فريقي بان يتصرف بسرعه لحمايتها
وفعلوا ذلك يوم الجمعه
المسؤول عن التنظيم
قام بالسيطره على
اصولي
سيليكون فالي بنك سيليكون بالي وكذلك
اتخاذ الاجراءات الفوريه وهنا بعض ونسلط
الضوء على اهم الامور كل العملاء يمكن ان
[موسيقى]
تاكدوا انهم محميين ويمكنه الوصول الى
اموالهم منذ اليوم
وهذه البنوك ستقدم
الاجور ولا يكون هناك اي خسائر
يتكبدها دفع الضريبه اي منهم لن يدفع اي
خسائر بل هي الرسوم التي سيدفعها البنك
وبسبب الاجراءات
وبسبب الاجراءات المتخذه فان كل امريكيه
يجب ان يضمن ان الاصول ستكون موجوده كلما
احتاجها ثانيا اداره هذه البنوك سيتم
اقالتها فان تسيطر عليه الابدي اي سي فان
الذين يديرونه لن يبقوا في العمل به
المستثمرين لن يحصلوا على الحمايه وقد
اتخذوا مخاطره لكن هذه المخاطره لم تنجح
وبالتالي المستثمر خسر
ورابعا بالنسبه لكيف وصلت الى هذه الحاله
اعني هذه البنوك فاننا لابد ان نعرف
تفاصيل ولماذا هؤلاء المسؤولين يجب ان
يتحملوا ويتحاسبوا على ذلك ولا احد فوق
القانون واخيرا يجب ان تقلل الخسائر
واداره اوباما بايدن
وضعنا شروط قاسيه على البنوك
وسلكوم بنك لضمان ان الازمه التي شهدناها
في 2008 لن تحدث مره ثانيه للاسف الاداره
تراجعت عن بعض هذه
الشروط وبالتالي يجب ان لا تكون هذه فقط
يمكن ان تتكرر وحمايه
المشاريع الصغيره لكن الخلاصه على الجميع
ان يكون مطمئنا ان النظام المصرفي امن
وايداعاتهم امنه ودعوني اؤكد لكم اننا لن
نتوقف هنا بل سنفعل كل ما يلزم واجراءات
قاسيه وضعونا ننظر للوضع في سياق اوسع
حققنا تقدم اقتصادي في السنوات الاخيره
واوجدنا 12 مليون وظيفه جديده اكثر من اي
عدد من الوظائف اوجدها اي رئيس وهي اقل من
اربعه بالمئه اعني هنا البطاله
وايضا الاجور ارتفعت
ونرى عدد من الذين يتقدمون لمشاريع
الصغيره 10 ملايين طلبت سنوات الاخيره
لبدء مشاريع جديده علينا ان نحافظ على هذا
التقدم وبالتالي لابد من اتخاذ اجراءات
سريعه
لحمايه المدعين والنظام المصرفي
والمكتسبات الاقتصاديه التي حققناها معا
شكرا لكم